hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 1
episode 5 the wolf in the lion an
episode that shows us even when men and
Game of Thrones disagree they still know
how to keep things civil yeah not quite
you know I gotta say of the classic
episodes every watched so far this one
was the most fascinating to look at in
retrospect the changes from the books
the ways major events were foreshadowed
or set into motion and the details I
didn't catch before specifically there's
a mystery of what varus's plan was in
those early seasons that will be one of
many things I talked about is we dive
deep into the wolf in the lion and break
down all the interesting stuff I Chi
okay like other episodes from Season 1
this episode featured a few new scenes
that were not at all in the books they
were written and shot purely for the
show Petyr baelish's war of words with
Varys Renly Baratheon and Loras Tyrell
steamy chests shaven and Robert and
Circe's amazing conversation honestly
these were three of the most fascinating
scenes from the episode so let's talk
about these and all the other
adaptations from George RR Martin's
source material in our segment well in
the books and let's start with Robert
and Cersei so the show's creators have
singled out this scene as one of their
favorite from the entire series and I
completely agree now it's not in the
books because neither Robert nor Cersei
had point-of-view chapters in a game of
Thrones book 1 it's a conversation
between two great characters in the book
that readers always dreamed of seeing
played out it does so much to
dimensionalize them as people and to
reveal deeper insights about their
relationship which otherwise would be a
little hard to make sense of like we
know Robert and Cersei hate each other
but seeing mark addy and Lena Headey
sharing can laugh over this sham
political marriage suddenly makes it
super clear how these two people see
each other that's all the realm is now
backstabbing and scheming and
arse-licking and money-grubbing
sometimes I don't know what holds it
together our marriage
in the books Robert's grudge over losing
Lyanna stark and Circe's jealousy of
that seemed a bit more straightforward
but in this scene adi and haiti get to
show us how these emotions are actually
far more complex and more deeply human
what harm could Lyanna Starks ghost do
to either of us that we haven't done to
each other a hundred times over you
wanna know the horrible truth even to
what she looked like
also notice how Cersei once again brings
up the Sun they had together I felt
something for you once you know you know
after we lost our first boy this should
remind us of Cersei bringing up this
child to Catelyn back in episode 2
proving that Cersei wasn't lying to her
then making Cersei actually a little
more sympathetic here and remember this
was changed from the book Cersei later
revealed in books if she aborted the
child she conceived with Robert now
there's another detail in this scene
that we'll come back to but let's also
look at the newly written scene
immediately before this one between
Loras Tyrell and Renly Baratheon now
earlier moments in this episode hint at
Renly's homosexuality and tell me Lord
Renly when will you be having your
friends just like this isn't much of a
secret with in King's Landing it doesn't
stay much of a secret to us either
my last breakdown I observed how
interesting it was to see Tyrians role
as an activator for fellow cripples
bastards and broken things Jon bran and
beyond inspiring them on their
respective character journeys in this
episode we see Loras play a similar role
for Renly encouraging him to overstep
his position as fourth alive or the Iron
Throne appealing to his ego and yeah his
a sexual appetite now earlier in the
hour before jousting the mountain Loras
offered a rose to Sansa Stark and even
though it was a cover for his true lover
Renly that must have at least perked
Renly on some level like made him wish
for a realm where he wouldn't have to
hide this relationship something he
could establish by being king in a way
this exchange parallels another famous
attorney the attorney of Harrenhal
decades earlier where a similar handsome
southerner Rhaegar Targaryen handed a
rose to a stark girl Lyanna pissing off
another Baratheon Robert who was so mad
that he launched a selfish pursuit for
the Iron Throne
so by including this scene
Loras and Renly the show reveals Renly's
motivation on a deeper level and perhaps
how it echoes past historical cycles now
before we get to this new scene between
Littlefinger and Varys I want to talk
about the way Tyrion story was adapted
this episode in the book the heroine
ascent through the a bloody gate up to
the Eyrie is described in detail from a
Catlins point of view it involved mules
trained to walk the narrow path and a
brief run and with her uncle the
blackfish now the show makes this
dizzying vertigo more of a reveal for
Tyrion later as he looks over the edge
of the Eyrie dungeon in the book the
floor of this chamber is actually
slanted toward the opening making Tyrion
afraid to sleep but the show did include
one other unnerving detail check out the
wall behind Tyrion someone wrote the
words time to fly in blood now this is
probably written by a previous prisoner
who went crazy in a Cell and who
scrawled this message just before
leaping to his death another slight
change in the book involved this scene
with Arya overhearing the conversation
between Varys and Illyrio in the dragon
dungeon beneath the Red Keep in the book
Varys actually disguises himself with a
goofy costume and he speaks in this put
on accent walks in a strange way
that's because Varys used to be a stage
performer in a traveling group of
mummers and he uses these techniques to
move and plot around King's Landing
without getting noticed in the show
various just pretty much wears a hood
over his head and I'm assuming they're
doing this because it's still pretty
early in the series and the viewers are
still getting used to who everyone isn't
what they look like and this secret chat
leads us to this fascinating boy fight
between Varys and Petyr Baelish at the
base of the Iron Throne now the season 3
chaos is a ladder scene between them is
probably better remembered but this
first clash establishes these two as the
true manipulators behind the events of
the whole series it starts with the two
men trading insults on which is more
dastardly Varys for exploiting children
to do his spine for him or Baelish for
his deviance in his brothel but then
that deepens into reveals that each of
them know the other's secret masterplan
Varys knows about baelish's continuing
love for Catelyn and his framing of
Tyrion Lannister in the assassination
attempt on bran
turning the Starks Lannister's against
each other but then Baelish knows about
varus's relationship with Illyrio and
his secret plotting for a Targaryen
restoration essentially this one scene
establishes Petyr Baelish as the
instigator behind the war of the five
kings don't consume Westeros for seasons
to come in Varys as the instigator
behind the Rye
of daenerys targaryen that will consume
esos for seasons to come
one conspirator betting on the West one
a conspirator betting on the East
however various reports to Robert via
jorah mormont that Daenerys is pregnant
so he's basically setting up Robert to
send an assassin to kill Danny her
unborn child and Viserys so what exactly
is Varys plotting at this point in the
series what was his original plan now
book readers have a better idea for what
this was but to talk about it it would
kind of spoil future events in the
series so if you haven't read the books
and you're just starting to watch the
show now skip to this time and actually
in a section I'm gonna discuss all the
ways this episode connects to and
foreshadows future events
so by skipping this time you'll bypass
anything that might spoil you cool great
by right there gone gone great for the
rest of you let's look at this episode
in hindsight so when Varys meets in
secret the Lirio Varys worries that the
conflicts that Littlefinger has stirred
up between the Starks and the Lannisters
is rushing their side of the conspiracy
and Illyrio says that Khal Drogo
wouldn't invade until his son is born
and proven healthy so this tells us that
Varys is plan involved some invasion by
the dothraki house Tina Baratheon zand
restoring the Targaryen stew the throne
but which Targaryen obviously not
Daenerys or Viserys if he reports to
Robert about Daenerys his progress in
pregnancy in Essos if he really cared
about Danny he would keep this all a
secret in book five A Dance with Dragons
we learn about Varys his secret strategy
while in exile from King's Landing
Tyrion meets a character named young
Griff who accompanies him in later Jorah
on their way to Dany and marine now
young Griff Varys reveals later is
actually Aegon Targaryen the son of
Rhaegar and Elia Martell now Varys
claims to have switched these babies out
and that Gregor Clegane killed a
different baby during the sack of King's
Landing
according to varus's story he says he
smuggled out this infant prince and hid
him away gradually over the years
grooming him to be the next king to one
day return to Westeros and to pick up
the pieces after the Baratheon and the
mad Kings children took each other out
but later as Daenerys turns out to be a
pretty successful ruler Varys seems to
change his plan to instead marry Aegon
to Daenerys and then have these two
Targaryen reclaim the Iron Throne
together now we'll see what george RR
martin does with this plot line when
book 6 comes out but in the show it
looks like they
completely dropped it and season five
Jordan Beaumont kidnapped Tyrion and
they made their way to marine without
any young Griff character who's never
cast for the show I just think it's
interesting how in hindsight despite
starting out as mastermind conspirators
both Varys and Littlefinger schemes end
up getting undone by the series more
central protagonist act in ways they
never could have predicted another
interesting mystery that came up while
Reed watching this episode pertained to
the death of Sir Hugh and how it
connected to the mystery of John Aaron's
death now in this episode Sir Hugh's
death was implied to be Cersei covering
up four tracks
essentially having John Aaron's old
Squire Sir Hugh killed to keep this
poisoning quiet but of course later we
learned that Liza not Cersei was the one
who poisoned Jon Arryn
so why was Sir Hugh killed then was this
just a red herring one theory is that
Littlefinger actually had Sir Hugh
killed to cover his affair with Liza and
his involvement these poisonings that
might be why last episode he was one who
told Ned to avoid talking to Sir Hugh
himself and that he should send an
emissary knowing that Sir Hugh would
rebuff anyone who he considered inferior
george RR martin was actually asked
about this and he left it for 'the fans
to decide but he suggested that the
mountain could have just killed sir hugh
because the mountain is just a ferocious
killer and that's what he do i guess
that makes it a pretty convenient
coincidence for Littlefinger and a very
inconvenient one first Sir Hugh by the
way yet you probably noticed that the
mountain was played by a completely
different actor back then that was conan
stevens from season four on he was
recast as the actual giant haftorah
bjornsen another interesting detail to
point out notice how after getting
locked in the dragon dungeon arya
actually ends up taking a tunnel through
the cave that lets out to the beach
outside and this is likely the same
passage that tyrion takes to get back
into this dungeon to secretly meet his
brother Jaime in season seven afterwards
arya tries to return through the front
door of the red keep arguing with two
guards who don't recognize it all want
to quit for all the good it does me you
want your father boy he's lying on the
floor of some tavern a very similar
scenario will occur later in season
seven when Arya returns to Winterfell
of course by then show I've learned to
outwit any dummies at the doors also
during the scene notice when
Littlefinger says this line to Varys how
does someone somewhere keep your balls
in the little box Varys keeps its cool
here but as we'll learn later
season three this is actually a very
ironic thing for Littlefinger to say to
Varys because that sorcerer that
castrated Varys is a young boy all those
years ago is actually kept by Varys in a
box honestly one of the weirdest loose
ends left on the show and this episode
shows us the end of Ned's right-hand man
Jory Cassell and we get this interesting
foreshadowing moment of his death when
he talks to Arya how many gods as my
father have here in King's London 15 no
I'm kidding would you know fear on that
count little lady hey don't hold your
breath
actually I was even more concerned by
jewelry revealing stark only has 50 men
we know last episode he gave a bunch of
his men to John of Slynt to keep the
King's peace during the tourney and this
episode Ned just said he's sent half of
them searching the city for Arya yeah
Ned really isn't using his limited
forces that wisely throughout the course
of the season it's becoming clearer and
clearer that they do not stand a chance
on the Lannisters start drawing blood
and Bri watching this I like the little
visual detail of Jory getting distracted
by one of the women in Littlefinger's
brothel it selves justify why minutes
later he was feeling so foolish and
cocky enough to take a swing at the
great Jamie Lannister in the battle big
mistake and on their way through the
bloody gate noticed this exchange
between Tyrion and bran
they say it's impregnable give me 10
good men and some climbing spikes I'll
impregnate the [ __ ] bran never wasn't
cool on the show Syrian actually repeats
this line later in season 7 when he lays
out his plan to sack his home of
Casterly Rock
silly rules intractable soldiers this is
a good friend of mine
give me 10 good men and Don impregnated
the [ __ ] and speaking of season seven a
cannot scene with Robert and Cersei he
actually offers some similarly prophetic
war strategy only a fool would meet the
Dothraki in an open field Robert goes on
to point out how Westeros would be super
screwed by any Dothraki invading force
and Cersei ends up learning that lesson
the hard way in the recent season when
her brother's army faces Robert's
nightmare head-on all right moving on I
want to point out some of these subtle
visual choices that I caught this
episode so let's look closely at some of
these shots in our segment zoom in
enhance this scene with master Liu in
bran and Theon it contains some
interesting details bran is depicted
looking down at the map of Westeros this
could be connected with brands visions
that he experiences around this time in
the book where he sees himself soaring
high over the continent of Westeros
looking down to this various family
members scattered across it and while
brand learns about the Greyjoy's family
failed rebellions Theon fires
arrow after arrow at the target getting
close to the bullseye but never actually
striking it the nice reflection of the
many failures awaiting Theon in his
future in the general imprecision of the
Greyjoy's in general later when Ned
meets with Varys notice the framing of
Ned with Varys in the background or
little angel or devil on the shoulder
this is very similar to that shot I
pointed out in episode 1 when Ned was
once again in the foreground but with
Catelyn and Luanne on either shoulder in
the background but in this case Ned is
under the influence of only one
manipulator suggesting that it's hard
for him to make a balanced reasonable
decision here later during the argument
between Ned and Robert over whether or
not to kill Daenerys Ned resigns and
drops his hand at a kingpin on the table
this visually echoes brand jabbing the
table earlier with his mother's house
Tully pen noticed the fish sigil this is
as he was criticizing his mother for not
following her own family's words family
of duty and honor putting duty and honor
before family and Ned is doing a similar
thing here he's putting his honor
refusing to partake in the death of an
enemy because she's young and pregnant
over the safety of his own family by
resigning he has put himself at odds
with the throne opening up him and his
men to an attack by Jaime and airman and
now let's discuss this episode's deeper
meaning again this episode's titled the
wolf in the lion a reference to Ned
Stark and Jaime's bloody duel at the end
of the episode
of course this collision was promised by
Varys earlier verbatim so this episode
shows us the first blood spilled in the
war of the five kings solidifying the
Starks and the Lannisters as mortal
enemies is interesting because in my
eyes this conflict between the two
families is ultimately unnecessary yes
there was some major personality
conflicts Ned Stark was never gonna be
invited to the lannister cool-kid table
but if you think about it there's no
strategic reason that these two can't be
allies they fought on the same side of
conflicts before in Robert's rebellion
and then later to quash the Greyjoy
rebellion they occupied completely
different regions of Westeros that
hardly interfere unlike the Lannisters
the Starks aren't particularly ambitious
they don't want the Iron Throne they
just want independence which their
geography already kind of gives them
really it was just some dumb mistakes
that turned these two families and
enemies Jaime of course pushing bran out
the window then really Littlefinger
manipulating Ned and Catelyn into
thinking the Lannisters killed Jon Arryn
and tried to murder bran but that wasn't
the case at all if not for those
mistakes I really don't think the Starks
would have even drawn themselves into a
game of Thrones with the Lannisters they
probably just would have stayed up North
stitching embroideries and running from
White Walkers so I think rather than
seen this conflict as inevitable in
retrospect it more closely resembles a
frustrating complication that ultimately
only serves to throw the world into
chaos it's not really a conflict we're
meant to see the conclusion of it's an
obstacle for the show's real
protagonists Jon and Daenerys who
interestingly don't show up at all this
episode notice how the title the wolf in
the lion mirrors the title of the most
recent seasons finale the dragon in the
wolf it's almost like saying the
relationship between the Starks and the
Lannisters is what puts the world into
peril but later the relationship with
the Targaryen Zin the Starks will be the
thing to save it but I could be wrong
here I want to throw it over to you guys
do you think the war between the Starks
and the Lannisters was avoidable comment
down below with your take or tweet me
directly at EI vas we're following new
rock stars on Twitter at new rock stars
for updates under videos now we're gonna
try to continue this game of Thrones
re-watch series more regularly and you
can help us by sharing this video if you
haven't already subscribed new rock
stars for lots of Game of Thrones
analysis and if you really like us you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our donors especially
Matt these solve us alright thanks for
watching guys bye